I'm Jack Sam's brother and we are here
in our backyard where we also live with
our other brother and Sam wanted to give
some advice about how to have an impact
on the world and since you couldn't
interview himself Here I am so Sam thank
you thank you for taking the time yeah
my pleasure
so to get started I think one of the
things that people talk a lot about is
how to get things done once you're
working on but I know you spend a lot of
time thinking about sort of what to work
on so could you talk a little bit about
how to pick what's important to work on
yeah um I think you want to look for the
intersection of what you're good at what
you enjoy and and what where you can
create value for the world and in my
experience if you don't find some of the
intersection of those three it's hard to
really have an impact I think most
people kind of just fall into what they
work on they don't give it much thought
and there is benefit to that sometimes
you actually have to just try stuff to
figure out what you like but I really do
think it is worth upfront thought about
what you're going to spend most of your
waking time doing so I think is really
good when people think about what
they're good at what they like and and
kind of how they can create value for
the world in sort of in addition to what
people are working on I know at Y
Combinator you talked a lot about who
people are working on things with yeah
how do you advise people to select sort
of who they're working on things with um
this is this is really hard finding your
tribe finding the sort of people that
you end up working with on and off for
the rest of your career is is really
hard I think I'll tell you some things
I've learned and I will admit that I
don't have a perfect answer to this yet
but I think one thing is you should be
willing to move for whatever you're
doing there tend to be pockets of it
around the world where there are similar
people that are doing great work in
whatever field you care about and it's
really worth trying to go be being near
them and so you know we get criticized
sometimes at YC for having people move
to the Bay Area but bringing people
together that are interested in this
similar thing of startups I think has
been really valuable for a lot of people
I think another thing that I have
learned is that whenever I've helped
people for no immediate benefit and with
no intention of ever getting to benefit
at all time and again in my career it is
really later benefited me a lot so I
think you at some point often get to a
point your career where you're limited
by how many good people you know and and
how many of those you can work with or
get to do things that together and so
fine just helping a lot of people and
spending a lot of time with a lot of
people has benefited me you know years
after I really helped someone for no
reason I get to invest in their startup
and it goes on to be a huge success or
were able to like work on opening I
together any number of things I think
just trying to help a lot of people and
out of that scene who is really
impressive and who gets things done is
helpful and in terms of how to actually
get things done so you've selected what
to work on who to work on it with you
think maybe you found your tribe and
then kind of now what what are what are
sort of the best ways to actually
accomplish big things well there's a
Charlie Rose quote on this that I've
always loved and I've since added one
more element to it but the quote is that
the way things get done in the world are
through a combination of focus and
personal connection and the additional
point I would make after having thought
about it for a while is that the third
factor is self belief it's you really
have to have a deep-seated personal
conviction that this thing you're going
to do that a lot of people say is really
stupid is going to work and going to be
important but I think those three things
focus personal connections and self
belief in my experience are how things
get done in the world so since you were
you know as long as you know you've
you've grown up and certainly three or
20s and now you've worked incredibly
hard and I know that a lot of the people
around you have worked very hard what's
sort of the advice or the way that you
think about your work-life balance in
your 20s and what do you recommend to
people who want to do these things and
also want to you know experience their
20s well I don't think I work as hard to
a lot of people I think I do work pretty
hard um but I'd say it's really I think
it's compound interest is a good
metaphor here if you work really hard at
the beginning of your career and you get
a little bit better what you do every
day every week every year and you learn
more and you meet more people and you
just get more done um there's a compound
effect and it's far better to put that
time in at the beginning
career then at the end because if you do
at the beginning you get to benefit from
it you know for the rest of the time you
work so you know one thing I always try
to do is like meet every person I had
time for go to every you know go to
everything I could and just like spend a
little bit more time trying to learn and
get better what I did what I do and I
think that is really valuable um the you
know the beginning of your career I
think in terms of studying the
trajectory that the rest of your career
follows is the most valuable time and so
obviously you don't want to work all the
time because your twenties your twenties
but I do think you want to work harder
than most people think you should and I
think that if you do that you tend to
benefit from it later life is super
unfair sometimes you also just get
unlucky and and so all you can do is
kind of maximize chances there but I do
think that working hard early in your
career to get the leverage and the
compounding effects is underrated and
one of the most valuable piece of advice
that I never got and so going into that
idea of these early years being
particularly valuable and working very
hard on things how do you decide when
you've worked on something long enough
and it's time to call it quits or when
you've worked on it for four years and
you're just about to have that
breakthrough how do you make that
distinction yeah this this is really
hard um knowing when to quit and knowing
when to give up on something is there's
no perfect answer to that but it's
really challenging to even get that
approximately correct I think most
people give up on things way too early
so the mistake that most people make is
they try something it does not
immediately work you see this
particularly in young entrepreneurs it
does not immediately work after seven
weeks they say you know what I tried
this thing it's just not meant to be and
I have too many other projects and so
they immediately give up and you kind of
you know the satirical version of this
is people that are 23 and have started
14 startups because they give up on
everyone before I could ever possibly
successful these things are really hard
they take a very long time there are a
lot of critics there are a lot of people
who say this thing sucks it's going to
fail it's really stupid and then also
there's like what at YC we call the
trough of sorrow where no one even
bothers to say it sucks because no one
cares at all
um and that is at least is demotivating
most of the founders that I have spent a
lot of time with that have gone on to be
super successful spent a very long time
on their idea when a lot of other people
would have given up and either people
said it sucks or people said nothing at
all and a framework that I have for when
to go up and when to keep working is it
should be an internal not an external
decision if people aren't using it or
people are saying it's bad that alone is
not a reason to give up you want to pay
some attention to that they might be
right but I think the best entrepreneurs
I know they make an internal decision
about when to give up or when to keep
working on something it's basically when
you have run out of ideas and something
is not working then it's a good time to
stop and so into this idea that you need
a long time to do anything important
what's the source of motivation for
people like what should people be
looking to find to be inspired or to
keep going on these ideas for a long
period of time
um yeah I think if you don't actually
believe what you're doing is really
important if you don't derive
satisfaction from what you're doing then
you will not be able to sustain all of
the bad things that happen an incredibly
long period of time that the bad things
happen over and so the only motivation
that I have seen work for people over a
long period of time is enjoyment and
what they're doing and an intense belief
that it matters and ideally liking the
people that they go to work with every
day um but the I think the reasons that
a lot of people and by the way it's
totally cool when people start off
saying well I want to make money or I
want to be famous I think a lot of
people start that way and they don't
like to admit it but pretty quickly or
at least in the first few years I think
a lot of people find a deeper mission
for why they do what they do
and that drives them than for the rest
of the time they work have you noticed a
change in what motivates you over the
last say 10 or 12 years um yeah I mean I
think I at this point I am sort of only
interested in things that I find sort of
interesting and important and early on
like a lot of other people I think I was
well I make money I want you know like
be in the press or whatever else and I
wouldn't say that doesn't motivate me at
all but it's honestly not a big factor
at this point yeah I just sort of like
there's a set of things that I think are
important and I want to work on this I
think another point about motivation
that is that people don't talk about
enough is related to burnout so I was
told and I thought for a long time that
you get burned out from working too hard
and at least in my own experience what I
found is that burnout actually comes
from failing and things not working
momentum is really energizing the lack
of momentum is super draining and I find
that I have infinite energy to work on
things that I find interesting and that
are working and almost none to work on
things that I either don't find
interesting or aren't working and so I
think you see a lot of founders try
something and fail and assume that they
just can't work hard enough or not
amount of energy or passion or whatever
and that's actually not true it's just
that that thing didn't work and what you
should do is shut that company down go
on vacation and try again and many
people then find that oh actually when
I'm doing this thing that I like and
that is working I have a huge amount of
energy and I can get a lot of stuff done
and so when you look at really
successful people and say how do they
get all those things done it's they have
the benefit of momentum and momentum is
energizing in the lack of momentum is
really not energizing working on a lot
of these problems that you know kind of
inspire this type of motivation are sort
of inherently riskier and I know you
know this is something that we've talked
about a lot about sort of the concept of
taking risk in a career being a repeated
game but how do you how do you think
about the idea of taking risks in your
career and how should people think about
it maybe differently than they currently
do well yeah I think people have
terrible risk calculus in general even
people who try to be really good about
this are bad at it um the answer I think
is almost always a you're wrong about
what is risking what it's not risky and
B most people don't take enough risk
especially early in your career being on
young and unknown and poor that is
actually a great gift in terms of the
amount of risk you can take
and I think people don't capitalize on
that enough I think what risk actually
looks like is not doing something that
you will then spend the rest of your
life regretting and there's a quote you
know people regret way more the things
they didn't do them things that they did
do so if you really believe in something
there's an idea that you're super
passionate about um you know and you
take a calculated risk to start a
company realizing you may forego a
couple of years of studying come in
another job and whatever else and you
know maybe people call you a failure or
whatever that's a great risk to take and
if you don't take that risk I think you
have a very high chance that you end up
regretting that um I think the wrong
kind of risk to take is where people
don't actually do things or don't commit
to something because they don't want to
fail and they over rate the risk of
failure and the reputation damage or
embarrassment or whatever I think one
really important thing to strive for in
your career is to be a doer not a talker
and the reason that people don't do
stuff one is it's hard and two is it's
risky and so you have these people that
you know want to dabble on a bunch of
different projects but never be all in
on one and I think it's this combination
of work and risk and it's you know I
think that's really bad I think history
belongs to the doers and I think you
should take a risk actually do something
don't just sit around and talk and
organize and bring together groups and
go to thought leadership conferences and
whatever it is these people spend their
time on other than actually building
something and just take the risk of
committing to what you you have
conviction on yeah and I think people
also seem to have sort of the fear of
being told no a lot and not asking for
what they want I'm sure that's something
that you've encountered with people yeah
um this was one of the other things I
learned that I wish I had gotten advice
on early in my career is ask for what
you want you will get told no a lot but
sometimes it will work and and I think
you see a lot of entrepreneurs shoot
themselves in the foot because they
don't ask
that person to quit the job and come
join them they don't ask this big
company to do a deal with them and
they're just not aggressive enough and I
think you being willing to ask what you
want and be somewhat aggressive are
really important characteristics of
being an entrepreneur people don't want
to fail they don't want to be told no
they don't want to end up in some crisis
another thing that I learned and I want
to say I wish someone told me this one
because I don't think it's a lesson
anyone can teach you you have to just
live through it is that each crisis gets
less scary than the one before it
you're running a company now I'm sure
you've I hope you've noticed this by now
you there are a lot of things that
really go wrong and they feel like
company killing events and they feel
like there's no way you're going to
survive because the crises are really
bad and the thing you learn is that you
generally do survive these and and that
the world doesn't usually end and even
if in the moment something happens you
have no idea how you're going to get
around it you eventually figure out a
way and because of that you know on the
19th major crisis you're like well I
survived the first 18 I'll probably get
through this one bit and you kind of
just do yeah definitely that rings true
so switching into a bit topic of sort of
money and sort of the long-term view of
it and how people can think about it
most clearly I'm actually to start with
a quick story that I think illustrates a
bit of some of your views this is from
when we were very young and our grandma
gave us each some stock oh this is a
good story in a company or you can tell
this one okay so she gave us each some
stock in a company that she thought we
would like and so as you like to point
out I was heavier as a child and one of
the things I liked was Appleby's and you
were hacking away on computers and other
things I was Apple and so we each got an
equal amount of Apple and Apple B's this
is like 20 years ago 20 years you know
and I think neither of us has sold it in
fact you nicely brought me my Appleby's
stock back from st. Louis recently your
stock certificates it's so long ago
still paper certificates and I think
inflation-adjusted I've probably lost
half my value there whereas I think your
Apple has gone up something
like I don't even want to think about it
hundreds hundreds yeah it's been a lot
how do you think about sort of the
long-term willingness to hold on to
things what are the advantages somebody
has early in their career how should
people think about money when they're
young yeah you know I still have those
uh Apple shares marked in my brokerage
account as grandma's birthday Apple
shares
I don't know I'm good I'm gonna keep
them I should benchmark them against
Applebee's um so I I think that one of
the few arbitrage opportunities left in
the market is time I think we have
gotten really good at high frequency
trading we've gotten really good at the
price of things we've gotten worse at
the long term value and I I don't think
you can go beat the market in a lot of
ways but the one way I do is is by
making a long-term commitment to
something I think that I my new belief
on how long I should hold stock and the
best companies I invest in is forever
and I think you know in a world where
people are increasingly focused on the
tick and the quarterly earnings cycle
you should try and go in the other
direction and this is a great way to
generate value and wealth and and so I
think that when you're thinking about a
startup it's really worthwhile to think
about something you're willing to make a
very long-term commitment to because
that is where the current void in the
market is um I think you know you get
paid as a founder for the wealth you
crave for other people so there's this
view of the world that business is all
about like trying to steal money and
sometimes that's true but but they're
the best companies just create massive
amounts of value for the world and then
they capture some of that for themselves
but they capture far less than they
create and they do it over a very long
period of time so if you're going to be
one of those companies
um I think you want to make a super long
term commitment to yourself and others
that are going to work on it with you
that this is going to take a long time
um but it is worth waiting because you
will make far more money over the long
horizon by doing this company really
well then a bunch of short-term things
along the way so how much do you think
people should have strong opinions about
things versus putting something into the
world iterating and sort of finding out
whatever works and going with that I
think you want a combination of those
two things you won't want to have a
strong opinion and then be flexible
about the details so the thing I don't
think works that often are the startups
on their love of the pivot that are
totally unrelated but I put a big
difference between refinement and
pivoting so when you start with a strong
belief you know we should have a social
graph in an online directory that is
Facebook has stayed pretty similar to
that although the product itself has
changed a lot along the way and I think
that's really good that is a strong idea
with flexibility in the implementation
and I think that's much better than the
we're just going to keep trying random
ideas because we want to have a startup
I think strong with strong opinions
about the future are really important
and I think one of the things that I
have noticed among the most interesting
the most successful people that I spend
time with is that they have strong
opinions strongly held about the future
they are willing to be convinced with
new data they are wrong but the bar for
that is fairly high and this idea that
the future is fundamentally unknowable
I've never liked actually I remember
pretty clearly this time war I was sort
of like spouting advice someone else had
given me in high school or college about
how you in you know you need to
diversify and investing because the
world is unknown unknowable and so all
you can do is have the most balanced
possible portfolio and I remember that I
was saying that out loud someone else's
said it to me probably grandma and and I
realized that I really didn't agree with
at all um because I had strong opinions
and then I knew that there were some
companies who stock I'd rather own than
others and I knew that I would rather
like own stock than own bombs because I
thought technology was gonna be worth a
lot more I have different ideas today
about the next 10 or 20 years um but I
think it's good it's not only okay it's
good to have strong ideas about the
future and it is okay to not be super
diversified in your investment portfolio
or your career or your life and then the
final question is if you could leave
young people who want to have a big
impact with one or two pieces of advice
what would you tell them well I don't
want to give people a specific field to
go work on because I think the whole
idea is that people need to figure out
themselves what they believe in and what
they think and what they believe is
high-impact to work on for the future so
what I will say instead is it is really
important to actually think hard about
where you think you can make the biggest
contribution that you're good at and the
world needs and that you enjoy and then
go meet people to work with go learn as
much about that field as you can and
then have the the courage of your
convictions to actually take a risk and
focus on it and go do something there
and that it's okay if you fail and if
you do fail you'll not be in much
different place than you are today and
you can go try the next thing but it's I
think really important to be willing to
go take a risk and make someone of
sacrifice to be able to try to impact
the world in some way that you really
care about and I think the sooner you
get to work on that the better you'll
you'll be awesome all right well Stan
thanks very much thank you jack